hello and welcome to the shiki-san shoe
so in this video I'll talk about why I
started taking nmn and look at the
safety of nmn safer baby he watched my
previous video about nmn the what the
why and the way it kind of looks like I
just dissipated myself to take the
supplement but I was actually taking it
before then and that was in quite a case
but what I didn't talk about last time
is the safety aspects of nmn and so as I
said at the end of my last video there
is currently no long-term Studies on the
safety of any men and humans and I said
I'll talk about this a bit more in this
week's video so here I am talking about
the safety of any men and also why I'm
taking at the first place so yeah once
I've explains why I take it I'll look
into the two main bits of concerns I see
in the literature mainly methylation and
potentially inflammation as well and
then lastly I'll say and discuss about
what you can do about this
so on the 31st of December 2019 I
started taking nmn which stands for
nicotinamide mono nucleotides and it is
a precursor to nad so as I explained in
my previous video nad is a key factor
that's really important for metabolism
and also the activity of nad dependent
proteins including some proteins
involved in the DNA damage response so I
would recommend watching that video
first before continuing with this one
but in case she didn't want to and also
because I go into the synthesis in the
last week's video you for a deep focus
on and it's always good to have a
refresher I have joined out this is
pathway here so we can see that nmn is
converted to NAD+ which is the main
thing to point out so far nad plus is
then consumed for example by three
enzymes pop one cd38 in south winds and
confided to
nicotinamide or and am I actually doing
a human to say it so you can actually
get nmn from your diet so elements in
broccoli and cucumber but you need to
have a lot of broccoli to get a high
dose of anyway so the alternative
strategy is to take nmn as supplements
so this is what I've been taking
for just over a week now so I take one
top of the day and - that is going to be
around 125 milligrams of nmn that I take
daily but the key question is well why
am I taking it so it is pretty well
established now that NAD+ levels the
client as we age and then studies that
have tried to restore these levels were
able to counteract and prevent many age
associated diseases and say they saw
improvements and extension inhale span
and lifespan but mostly studies have
been done in organisms such as mice for
the fact that they saw improvements in
physical performance muscle regeneration
and helps prevent decline in vision
these are all kind of really outstanding
phenotypes that they saw any studies
even the one about improvements in your
protective benefits so I guess this is
really the main reason why I decided to
start taking any men
not because I want to live forever but
just because it would be nice you know
not to you know lose my sight or my
physical performance but I think the
more important reason is more the
scientist in me who is just intrigued to
see what happens and yes I knew that
curiosity killed the cat and I am
definitely curious to see what does
happen but this is why I'm gonna now
move on to looking at what is known
about the safety of taking an ax men as
a supplement and should I be scared is
the the other question so what is known
about nmn safety well I came across a
2016 study where they had my steak and
men for 12 months and they saw no
toxicity but you know the thing is well
I'm not a mouse and as I said at the
start there has currently been no
long-term reports of the safety of any
men in humans so what are the potential
safety concerns whilst reading about the
literature there are like two main
categories one looks at the issue of
methylation and a more recent study
which I've not seen anyone really talk
about is a link between nmn and
inflammation so firstly let's look at
the potential risk of methylation and
what people are talking about in terms
methylation so what most people seem to
be
talking about profit guards to an
immense supplementation and increasing
NAD+ levels is that you have the first
effect of decreasing the availability of
methylation donors so out of the
different and AD derivatives
nicotinamide na em can get methylated to
one methyl nicotinamide or mean um I
think that's quite fun glad to see but
to generate Menem you use up Sam and Sam
is a methyl donor and in addition to
minami you also generates s-adenosyl
homocysteine which can then get
converted to homocysteine and say if you
have increased nicotinamide because you
caught excess and 80-plus you use up
these methyl donors that means that
there's less Sam available for other
molecules such as creatine and dopamine
and in addition to the loss of the
methyl donors there's also evidence that
having high homocysteine levels could
increase your risk of vascular disease
so you know maybe it's not looking good
but that's what people are saying so how
true is this and how relevant is this to
an immense documentation well again as I
said we just don't have the evidence at
the moment but I did come across a
recent paper that looks at the safety of
nitrogen which is nicotinamide by
besides chlorides which as you saw
earlier on is converted to n MN and then
NAD+
so I have put a link in the description
to this paper but the title is safety
and metabolism of long-term
administration of nitrogen and a
randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trial of
healthy overweight adults what a
mouthful so you they say that this study
is long-term say they attitude of eight
weeks and they did it with different
doses of niacin and so I just put some
of the results up here so one thing they
obviously measured was the blood NAD+
levels to see if they do see an increase
um during the periods which is one thing
like kidney to me fast before you start
looking at the safety issues and say as
they went from 100 milligrams up to 1000
milligrams they did see an increase in
percentage of NAD+ from 22 up 242
percent increase but I'm at 356 and they
see slight increases as well or they
looks like it's kind of plateaued which
is kind of interesting but what about
the hey mr. thin levels well they also
look at this and what they saw was
regardless of whether the patients took
none 10300 or one gram of nitrogen they
actually didn't see any difference so
that doesn't really seem to be a risk
with homocysteine levels but again this
is Niger not animun and also I wouldn't
really say a weeks is a long time but
you know it's better than nothing but
the reason I flagged up methylation is
partly juice the reason that it's not
too sure how element gets transported
into cells so there seems to be some
evidence that mmm has to be converted to
an R before it gets transported but
there's also potential evidence that an
Amanda could also just be converted to
nicotinamide and as we know that might
increase the hey mrs. D levels so I
think it's worth pointed out that this
definitely is a potential issue so but
it's all just one the question mark at
moments so what can you do about it so
one potential solution is to increase
the levels of these methyl donors and
you can do that by supplementing with
trimethylglycine which is what I am
doing but not as frequently as I take in
a man so another warning for taking nmn
has come from a paper that was published
in Nature that talks about the link
between nmn nad and information and
senescence so maybe because those paper
is more recent
I don't know but I've not really had
many people talk about this risk
associated with an immense
supplementation so the title is energy
plus metabolism governs the
pro-inflammatory senescence associated
secreting now there might be a few scary
words in that title but I'll try and
break it down as much as I can so
firstly the semesters associated to
presume is often referred to as the Sask
we'll come back to that in a little bit
but the bottom line is that this paper
seems to suggest that if you
increased energy plus levels you
increase inflammation and an
inflammation we know drives aging or
it's one of the hallmarks of aging so
this paper mainly focuses on cellular
senescence which I talked about before
in the home of aging and it can be
thought of as when cells stop dividing
and instead you can see them to create
different molecules mainly cytokines and
inflammatory molecules which is referred
to as the senescence associated
secretory phenotype or the SAS so
senescence is a really complicated
process that we are still trying to
understand in fact my PhD - bleh -
senescence but in terms of this video
i'll mainly figures about the findings
of this paper and so the key thing you
need to know is that the cells secrete
these plate pro-inflammatory cytokines
which I just put on my sibling molecules
that recruiting immune cells and so what
this caper seems to suggest is as we
know that nicotine mind gets converted
back to nmn and then anime and gets
converted to nad plus you end up
increasing the nad plus ratio if you
supplement with n MN and this increase
in the ratio of nad + to the reduce form
NADH represses the activity of a protein
a MP K which is a MP kinase and this
protein would normally activates p53 and
p53 inhibits another preysing called p38
MAP kinase so I mean that's a little bit
relevant information the key thing is
that if you increase the nhdplus levels
the downstream response is that you end
up activating p38 MAP kinase and say p38
MAP kinase is known to interact with NF
Kappa B and NF Kappa B is known to drive
the production of these different
cytokines involved in this asp
and then the SAS drives inflammation and
inflammation drives aging it's kind of
the summary from this paper but I mean
this is just this is just one paper at
moment and I mean these bindings need to
be backed up and plus most of the
studies in this paper I did it in cells
there were already some essence
obviously I mean again we do accumulate
senescent cells as we age but I think
that it really isn't enough evidence
either name and for this to be
convincing or to be too concerned until
it's further backed up with more
evidence to really understand what is
going on but definitely there could be
positive and negative effects of taking
an ax men but it's whether or not the
positives outweigh the negatives but
yeah going back to this paper again they
do states in their conclusion that NAD+
augmenting dietary supplements may be
tumorigenic in vivo in stress conditions
such as pre malignant senescent lesbians
induced by activated oncogenes so I mean
there is a risk but again like you know
how how much risk can I take I mean I
think the biggest risk for me is
probably my age like obviously I'm quite
young and that's the long-term effects
is what we really don't know in addition
to the short-term effects so yeah as I
said earlier curiosity make your cuts
but I think I've got to be okay to be
honest I'm not too concerned we'll see
what happens
anyway I'm hopefully this has been an
interesting video for you to understand
why I'm taking an event but also you
know there are concerns with its safety
don't just do something because I'm
doing it please ask your doctor fast but
as always hopefully this was interesting
and thank you for listening